right time for today's bar chart how low
can the yen go this is a two-year chart
december the 26th 2012 that was the day
that shinzo abe took the reins as
japanese prime minister we start there
and we finish
there back when arby took power the yen
was 85 to the dollar today after a 37
gain in the dollar in the interim the
yen has fallen to 117 that's the seven
year in less than three weeks by the way
after the boj expanded its already
unprecedented monetary stimulus the yen
has fallen by seven percent it's
followed by seven percent so how low
could the yen go try 140 yes i did say
140 against the dollar that's a level
last seen in 1998 according to sock gen
global strategist albert edwards that's
how far he says the yen could fall by
march that's a 20 decline from here bnp
parabans chief japan economist retaro
cono says investors will start
speculating on an exchange rate of 130
in late 2015 and 140 in 2016 as shinzo
abe does whatever it takes to haul the
economy out of recession are analysts as
bearish on the yen as those two
gentlemen know they're not
according to the median forecast of more
than 40 analysts surveyed by bloomberg
the yen will actually rise to 114 by
march and then drop to 119 by the end of
2014.
and interestingly if you look at the
options market it does seem that most
strategists are yet to catch up with the
end slide which is the point made by
sock jens edwards he says analysts can
struggle to keep up when markets shift
violently and to quote him he says it's
mainly the fear of being wrong that
prevents them from making bold forecasts
despite consistent evidence that markets
are far more volatile than their mundane
forecasts ever suggest you couldn't call
edward's forecast at the end could fall
to 140 by march mundane watch this space
to see if he's true